the old left right divide
is breaking down a little bit
the left right divide is not some
permanent
uh eternal sort of way to understand
politics the left right divide only
comes about
during the french revolution and it
refers to people who were sitting on the
left and
they were the radicals and the
revolutionaries and people who were
sitting on the right they were the more
conservative elements
they wanted to preserve the monarchy
they wanted to preserve hierarchy and
social order
so the way the way that we use left and
right it can kind of change and
circumstances change and the parties
change too
and there's some issues that bring this
up so there was recently
a poll out from a left-leaning pole
source
that shows that most people
reject gender ideology
specifically with regard to girls sports
most people do not think that men
should be able to compete in girls track
meets and win their
prizes and win their scholarships
how is this the issue that unifies
people because if you think of all the
big issues facing the country
most people if you were just thinking
about it for two seconds you'd say oh
girls sports i don't know that's way way
down on the list that barely matters at
all
except it represents
so much of the rot that is at the heart
of our entire politics
the reason that the transgender issue
has been able to kind of crack up some
of the left-wing
consensus and has aroused the passions
of conservatives is not because we
particularly care about women's sports i
don't i don't know that i've ever
watched women's sports or maybe the
olympics are on i'll say stuff but
very rarely it's because it's so
unjust and it's so obviously unjust and
it is so
out of whack with reality when you see
some big
hulking dude running circles around the
little girls running on the track court
you just
know oh this isn't right
well you and then some egghead you know
liberal will say well no but actually
the way that the hormones in the body
and the way that this in the
the science shows and you say like no
sorry
you can give me whatever egghead
ridiculous cockamamie explanation you
want
i just know that's not right because
you have all these very advanced social
theories
that you are combining with your social
scientific theories to give me some
explanation
of why husky hank over there should be
allowed to compete against
all those little girls but i have two
eyes and i just know it's wrong
and i noticed that the guys keep winning
all the games
so it would seem that my two eyes are
more reliable than your ridiculous
theories
among this uh the people surveyed 59
support a ban of and the wording here is
key a ban
of uh biological males from competing
against biological girls in female
athletics
46 of women support a band so it's lower
but 34
oppose a ban so far greater percentage
support the ban among republicans it's
about
three to one democrats 40 percent
support a ban 42 percent oppose a ban so
democrats identified democrats are the
only people
who slightly more oppose the ban
independence though it's overwhelming 49
support the ban 33 percent opposed gen z
is about evenly split
on this because they've been steeped in
gender theory and because they're young
and don't know what they're talking
about yet
uh millennials so millennials who are
often considered more
liberal more to the left in many ways
than gen z
overwhelmingly support the ban baby
boomers
roughly around the same percentage
actually they're a little less likely to
support the ban
than millennials so these numbers are
changing by generation but that might
change as people get older too
i also want to focus in here on the
wording of this of this uh
the coverage here so the coverage is is
referring to biological males and
biological girls i understand
why people do that i know a lot of
conservatives who do that too
but i think it's a bad idea i think it
is mistaken
i think it is giving in to political
correctness
there is no such thing as a biological
male
as distinct from a spiritual male or a
psychological male
there are just males there's just dudes
okay
and the reason people use this term
biological male is they want to be very
very precise and they want to make these
arguments from biology and they want to
say that actually
it's the physicality of the person and
the physicality is somehow different
than the soul or the spirit
and that is the transgender argument
when you say the phrase biological male
you are making the transgender argument
the transgender
argument is that there is a difference
between one's biology
and one's other identity
and the transgender people say that this
other identity this metaphysical
identity that's my true identity and my
body
has nothing to do with it but when the
right comes out and says
biological males or biological girls
they're just making the flip side to
that argument they're saying yeah
there's a difference between
your biological identity and your other
kind of identity your spiritual identity
whatever you want to call it
but your true identity is your
biological identity but the actual
conservative argument
is that we are not split between our
soul and our body they're not completely
separate entities
we are one entity the the
technical term for this is hylomorphic
beings
right the body and the soul are fused
where they're they're inseparable on
earth and so it's you
when you when you divide it up even if
you're dividing it up to argue with the
left on the transgender question
you're actually giving them their
argument this is i hate to plug my book
two times in a show but this actually is
kind of the argument here this is what
we do all the time on the right
is even when we think we're fighting
against the left when we think we're
fighting against political correctness
and locism and cancel culture we're just
giving in we're just giving in in a sort
of different way that we're not even
conscious of
we really ought to stop doing that
because i do think we're in a moment
of real political chaos and chaos breeds
opportunity
there are things that are shifting here
if you've got the majority of people
see with their own two eyes oh my gosh
wow look how crazy this is
these this left-wing ideology on gender
is so nuts what else
is nuts about their ideas this is a good
opportunity to grab it but we're not
going to win that
by acquiescing and giving in on an issue
that is overwhelmingly
in our favor because it's so clear
what this comes from is uh you know
this minor relatively trivial issue of
the girls sports
comes from this broader issue which is
that we no longer want to
admit that some things are normal and
some things are abnormal
there are norms there are standards we
even on the right we don't want to admit
that we want to say well you do you you
do whatever you want you pursue your own
appetites and desires you
be free as though that's really what
freedom is it's not it's not even close
to freedom it's not what the founders
thought freedom was it's not what any
sophisticated people have thought
freedom is in our history but it comes
down to norms it comes down to standards
are you allowed to say this is normal
this is not i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the michael knowles show to check
out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen
to podcasts